a la corte penal internacional
investigará presuntos crímenes en los
territorios palestinos a través de un
comunicado la fiscal general del
organismo fatou bensouda anunció la
decisión hoy confirmó el inicio por
parte de la fiscalía de la corte penal
internacional de una investigación sobre
la situación en palestina la
investigación abarcará delitos de
competencia de la corte que
presuntamente se han cometido en
palestina desde el 13 de junio de 2014
fecha a la que se hace referencia en la
remisión a la corte de la situación la
autoridad palestina dio la bienvenida al
fallo al igual que el grupo hamas en
gaza
consideramos que esta decisión es un
paso adelante en el camino hacia el
establecimiento de la justicia y el
castigo de la ocupación por sus crímenes
y la reparación de las víctimas de
nuestro pueblo palestino la decisión se
produce después de que el 5 de febrero
el tribunal dictaminará que tiene
jurisdicción en el caso una medida que
provocó un rápido rechazo de washington
y tel aviv
el tribunal que se estableció para
evitar la repetición de los crímenes
nazis cometidos contra el pueblo judío
ahora se está volviendo en contra del
estado
pueblo judío y está haciendo la vista
gorda ante irán siria y otras dictaduras
que están cometiendo crímenes de guerra
reales
la investigación siguió un minucioso
examen preliminar realizado por la cpi
que duró cerca de cinco años la cpe
indicó que había bases razonables para
investigar sobre el comportamiento de
las fuerzas armadas israelíes durante la
guerra de gas en 2014 así como del
movimiento hamás que aún gobierna la
zona israel no se ha suscrito a la cpi
motivo por el que rechaza su
jurisdicción sin embargo palestina es
miembro del tribunal lo que abre las
puertas a las pesquisas